as for the moment of leaving the church I
kneel in front of the altar I
suddenly felt as I got up
escaping hawthorns odorless bitter and sweet
of almond and I then noticed on the
flowers of small e place  blond under
which I imagined myself and perhaps
hiding this smell like that of the
private parts and the taste of a frangipane or
on their freckles that
of Mademoiselle Bellevue's games despite the
silent immobility of the hawthorns this
intermittent smell was like a
murmur of their intense life whose free hotel
is as well as greece is visited
by lively people making a theme that we
thought of when seeing certain vitamins
almost boiling what seemed to have kept
the spring virulence the
irritating power of insects today
metamorphosed  in flowers we chatted for a
while with monsieur a moment with
monsieur vinteuil in front of the porch on
leaving the church
he intervened between the kids who were
bickering on the plaza  e take the
defense of the little ones was sermonizing
spunk if his daughter said in her big
voice how happy she had been to
see us immediately it seemed when
she leads a sister more sensitive to the
cost quantified this good boy remark and
who told me  that they had been able to make
believe that she was asking to be accomplished
her father throwing a coat over her
shoulders he was getting into a small buggy
which drove herself
and all of us to return to my place as
for us as it was the following day
Sunday and  we only take it for the
great masses if it's moonlight for you
and koehler was hot instead of
making us go home directly my father for
love of glory made me do for
which towards a long walk that the
little  my mother's ability to orient herself
and to recognize herself in her path he
was considered unlikely
afro s of a strategic genius
sometimes we go to the viaduct
whose spanning stones began at the
station and m  e represent exile and
distress outside the civilized world
because each year coming from
paris we were recommended to be
very careful when it would be
overwhelmed not to let the station pass
to be ready in advance because the train
left two  minutes and engage
on the viaduct beyond the Christian countries
whose congress marked for me at the extreme
limit we returned by the boulevard
of the station where were the most pleasant
villa of their commune in each garden
the moonlight like hubert robert  it's
not that effect broken tomorrow in white
these jets of water burned out half-opened
its lights had destroyed the
telegraph office it was no longer enough that a
column allowed broken but it keeps the
beauty of a street nor mortal i  dragged
my leg I fell asleep the smell
of fragrant lime trees seemed to me
like a reward that could only be
obtained at the cost of the greatest
fatigue and which was not
worth it  from each
other dogs awakened by not
solitary ones made alternate
barking as it still happens to me
sometimes from time to time only in the evening
and between which to come there when on
its site created the public garden
of cambrai to take refuge the boulevard of
the station because wherever I am as
soon as they start ringing and
answering each other I see it everyone except and
its sidewalk
lit by night all of a sudden my
father stopped us asked my mother
where are we exhausted  by walking but
proud of him she admits waiting for him
missed in knowing absolutely nothing he was
shrugging his shoulders and riel then as
if he had taken out of his
jacket pocket with his key he shows us is
standing in front of us the small back door
from our garden who had
come with the corner of the rue du
saint-esprit waiting for us at the end of
these unknown paths calls me my mother
said to me with admiration
you are extraordinary and from that
moment I don't  I'm not going a single step to
do the only market for me in this
garden for so long but the act
had ceased to be accompanied
by voluntary attention the habit
had just taken me in its arms and
carried me to -8 like  a little child
if the day of Saturday which started
an hour earlier and where she was
deprived of Françoise Pacé more slowly
than another for my aunt she
had been waiting
impatiently for her return since the beginning of the
week as containing all that  is the
novelty the distraction that I am
still able to support his
weakened and maniacal body and it is not
however that sometimes he did not yearn for
some greater changes than her
him from his hours of exception where my thirst
for something  something other than what is
and where what the lack of energy
or imagination prevents from drawing from
themselves in principle of renovation asks every
minute that comes to the postman who
rings to bring back something new burst out of the
worst one  e emotion a pain or the
sensitivity that happiness has silenced
like a neighboring bow
you reason under a hand even brutal
and from the teil be broken by it or the will
which has so difficultly conquered the right
to be delivered without obstacle to its desires
to  these shovels would like to throw the reins
into the hands of internal events, even if
it were cruel 112 like
my aunt tahri's strength at the
slightest fatigue came back to her drop by
drop within her purpose the fact
of having been very far to fill  and it
was months before she alone
and I too full that other drifts
in the activity and of which one was
unable to know and decide
how to use
I do not doubt that then like the desire
of the  replace with potatoes
b never finished sap of some time per
letter of the same pleasure that I have kozel
daily returns of the mash of which she
does not get tired of saying it to of
the accumulation of these monotonous days to
which she held the time  the ten
of a domestic cataclysm to limit the
duration of a moment but which would force her
to accomplish once and for all
one of those changes which she
recognized which would be beneficial to her and
which she could not
decide on her own is  genuinely
enjoyed them complaining
occurring at a time when
she felt good and the deceased sweating
the news that the house was engulfed
in fire we had all perished already
and they were soon not going to
let stand  a single stone from the
walls, but from which she would have had
plenty of time to escape without hurrying on the
condition of getting up immediately, must have
often haunted her communist hopes
as a secondary advantage of winter to
savor in a willing number all her
tenderness for  we is to be the
amazement of the village leading
another courageous grieving overwhelmed moribund
standing the far more precious one of
strength and at the right time with no time to
waste
no possibility of hesitating  irritating
to go and spend the summer in his pretty to
return to the grains where there was a
fall
like no
event of this kind had ever occurred of which he meditates is
certainly the success when I was
alone absorbed in his innumerable games
of  patience and that he is desperate at the
first beginning of realization at the
first of these small unforeseen fact of
this word announcing bad
news and I can never again
forget accent what bears
the imprint of real death very
different from this  logical
and abstract possibility she fell back to
make it no longer interesting to introduce from time to time
imaginary adventures that he followed with
passion she liked to suppose all
of a sudden that françoise la volley
what recourse to cunning  for
sure taught her about doing it
used to when she played alone these
games of playing cards both her
game and the game of her
opponent she decided herself  me
Françoise's embarrassed apologies he answered
with so much fire and indignation
that one of them we enter at these
times find her in age with sparkling eyes
these reapers place and letting see his
own show François to hear you
sometimes heard from the
next room biting sarcasm
addressed to her is in the invention
not to give herself enough expectations
if I had remained with the
immaterial clearance and on him murmuring in a low
voice is theirs would have given them  no more
reality
sometimes this show in a bed
was not even enough for my aunt she
wanted to have her plays performed so one
Sunday all doors mysteriously
closed she confided to al ahly her doubts
about Françoise's probity her
intention to get rid of them and
another time to françoise these suspicions of
the infidelity of him to whom the door
would soon be closed a few days
later they were dismissed from this
confidence of the day before ra quo which had them
be a
traitor who, moreover, for their
next performances would exchange
their jobs but the suspicion that
eulalie could sometimes inspire in him
was only a flash in the pan quickly fell for
lack of food from the city
not living in the house it was not
not the same with regard to the
French women that my aunt is
perpetually the same you what sense
that for fear of catching cold if she
got out of bed she dares to go down the kitchen to find out if it was
justified